you know like sometimes people come to
be like [__] you Gary I've been doing it
for 7 years and I have 1,800 followers
and get two likes I'm like it's not that
social doesn't work cuz there's billions
of examples of it working it's that you
haven't found it like what you're doing
isn't resonating with the world and
that's on you to either not care because
you like doing it and [__] it you got
your 1,700 followers and you're [__]
living or if you want something else
you've got to change it you got to
change the creative format the way you
present maybe you shouldn't be in the
content you should be behind SC there
could be a million reasons this is going
to be the easiest interview in my life
because I love this guy deep in my soul
Gary you've inspired the world through
just real life hard work and you
showcased it on a day-to-day basis on
how they can actually do it where most
people talk factiously you say this is
how you guys actually do it make pieces
of content go do the work you never try
to make it fake walk us through why you
show your content like that and why this
should actually followed through with
those
steps you know I think especially with
the energy of this room and what an
incredible lineup and obviously the
energy of this crowd is off the charts
when you to that point I think for the
ogs In This Crowd call it 42 and above
years old a lot of us In This Crowd that
are of that age realized that
entrepreneurship wasn't in the zist of
popular culture when I was growing up
there weren't entrepreneurs to look up
to it wasn't a thing it was all about go
to the best college you can get into and
go into the corporate game and
so as things evolved with the internet
and social media there was a point where
I realized oh [__] entrepreneurship is
now cool and that was neat and I thought
that was [__] amazing and I was like
in it and I was like okay let's
understand what this means and then over
the next 3 to four years it became
obvious to me that a lot of people
talked about it because it became cool
the way they would talk about sports or
being a rapper like kids in high school
are like I'm going to make the league
I'm going to be in the NBA or I'm going
to be a famous rapper that wasn't the
way that people talked about being an
entrepreneur but that had started to
happen because entrepreneurship became
popular culture it was then that I was
like you know what there's so much
confusion of what it is required to pull
this off and I think for everyone in
this you know conference the more you go
through it I don't know where everyone
is on their Journey but the more we go
through it the more you realize like you
can fake it for a while but it's just
not sustainable and for me I got lucky
because this all didn't happen when I
was 17 this all happened when I was in
my late 30s I was already on the back
end of putting in the work
the other thing that I desperately wish
for everyone here more than how much
money they are able to make is for them
to be happy and I mean that because
everyone here knows unlimited people
that have money that are having terrible
lives they're anxious they're they're
they've got real issues and there's
nothing good about that so it became
important to me seven eight 10 years ago
to really do what I could to show that
the truth of the matter is is that the
work is part of the equation that you
aren't looking for the quick way to do
it you're looking for the most
sustainable way for you to do it and
really be being self-aware and reverse
engineering who the [__] you are and
then putting yourself in a position to
do that is always going to lead to the
thing that everybody wants and so you
know I felt it it was in my stomach and
I wanted to put it out there and I did
and and obviously it led to people
seeing maybe a different version of it
I'm thrilled when people use me as a
proxy of what they want to do or of what
they don't want to do plenty of people
in these circles will come to me and be
like Gary I don't believe in what you're
saying I'm like that's amazing like do
you like I don't think I'm right I think
I'm right for me and and I and I think
that means it's right for some of you
and then it means that it's some parts
of what I do is right for you and that's
the [__] game
Dan so when you walk through it so clean
and simple of like this is what you do
over and over and over for one years two
years three years four years and if you
do this every day you'll get there what
do you actually think when people don't
follow through with those things like
why don't people actually follow through
with the simple game you give them um
well there's a million variables that go
into that like you know the biggest
thing that is holding back all of us me
included from whatever we want is not
recognizing things not seeing it right
like I didn't realize for 25 years as a
manager that my lack of cander Gary VE
for all of you is very canderous it's a
strength Gary vaynerchuk the CEO of
2,000 people at Vayner X struggled with
cander because if I like you it's harder
for me to say something you know this is
you know when you're posting you're
posting to the world so you're not
talking to anybody specifically when
you're talking to a direct report that
you're in the trenches with every day
they become your brother and sister they
they become family when you're really
about it and it's sometimes hard to tell
them they stink at something because for
me the number one thing I hate in the
world is fear I hate fear and a lot of
people weaponize fear to get people to
do what they want politicians teachers
parents fear is weaponized often I used
to think that me telling you if you were
working for me Dan like hey Dan you're
really like you're awesome but like
you're not great at this this and this
and like if you don't fix it like this
is not going to work out I thought when
you would walk out that you were scared
and that you were like halfway out the
door and self-esteem was [__] up and I
was and I didn't know how to find that
balance I've been able to fix that in
the last five years and it's changed a
lot for my company and my world I didn't
see my lack of cander as a Kryptonite
the reason so many people here don't
follow easy things is one it's not easy
for them I've started to get serious
about my health about 10 years ago and I
go to the gym pretty consistently but to
this day I [__] hate it like like to
waking up tomorrow and it's going to
rain in New York and the [__] jets
are going to probably lose tomorrow and
and so I'm already in a bad mood and
waking up at like 8 and having to like
put in a workout is like the least
natural thing yet if you told me Gary we
need to work 98 hours straight on this
to solve it I'd be like let's start
right now that's easy so for a lot of
people it doesn't come natural the
reason Dan I think for a lot of people
it doesn't come natural is they're
chasing the financial part of it and so
by chasing the financial part of it they
don't really like it which is why they
want it to happen faster which is why
they don't follow the work ethic
required I understand that because
that's how I lived my life in health and
wellness and that's how I lived My Life
as a student student I didn't like it
which is why I sucked at it and there
was no no thing I could do to fix those
two areas but in Business and
Entrepreneurship I loved it it's my life
I'm pure [__] bred entrepreneur I
like the game and so it comes easy but I
think what I'm hoping is that if people
realize in this new internet world that
is now mature that we all live in they
can instead of chasing the next Trend if
they chase a category of passion
something they like
and built a business around that they're
far more likely to pull it off because
when they wake up they actually want to
do it cuz the thing is interesting not
the [__] they get from the
thing so back in 2019 you led me to a
passion project we were at a sports card
convention called the national 100,000
people there I just happen to be in
Chicago Gary's there he's got his booth
there and I come by the the card show
and you've got at the time like 900
employees now you have 2,000 you had
like 900 employees and I watched you buy
a sports card for 60 bucks and spend an
hour negotiating with someone else to
sell it for 100 bucks so you're going to
make $40 while you have 900 employees
back home and I it's burned into my mind
why like what what is so much about the
game or what $40 [__] dollars in
profits a [__] come
up but but I'll let you finish but I
just want to go back like
that story is real and it's completely
the followup to what I just said me
buying a sports card for 60 bucks from
one booth walking around for an hour and
then selling it for A1 and making those
$40 gets my juices going way more than
when Vayner media lands a $10 million
account and it's not even [__]
close if you can find that in your
actual day-to-day you will get much
further than you can ever imagine CU
you'll have the [__] fuel to get
it so for people out there that are
trying to figure out the thing that they
like sports cards and Pokemon working
for an accountant a lawyer real estate
selling door too selling solar working
with these companies like how do they
find that thing that makes them excited
you have to taste [__] I texted seven to
10 people to come by the national in
Chicago in 19 you said yes you had no
[__] idea idea you just showed up and
then it led to something the amount of
people here that start conversations
with no breaks my
soul most of the best [__] that was ever
destined to happen in your life you said
no
to we have to especially this crew one
of the teners of business or
entrepreneurial success is to be in the
business of maybe instead of the
business of no if if you're in the
business of maybe you spend a little
time double clicking into [__] if you're
in the business of no you already
lost there's so many people here Dan
that say well Gary I say no because I'm
saving my time my time is precious when
their time isn't worth as much as they
think it's [__]
ego your time's not as valuable as you
think and understanding the power of
maybe is humongous and so the way they
all figure it out is by saying maybe
which leads them to doing 7 to 20 things
or going to 7 to 20 things that they
wouldn't have prior and in one of those
seven to 20 things is the [__]
thing so often times people have like a
goal number like once I make 100 Grand a
year or I make 250 a year or once I buy
the house or once I make a million a
year once I make 2 million but the goal
post always moves what are your thoughts
about when people have these numbers or
these goals in their mind for that
Financial game I think this is
self-awareness game I think for some
people here those goals really work for
me I just made up something when I was
12 that was so big that it allowed me to
play forever to buy the new yor buy the
Jets right and so are you going to buy
the Jets am I going to buy the New York
Jets yeah I think I
am but you know when I clip this in 40
years when I don't buy them and have to
explain what the [__]
happened I won't be upset
because I am focused on what I can
control build the biggest and most
sustainable and best and healthiest
businesses I can to put me in a position
that if the Serendipity of the world and
the timing and the stars align that add
a time when I can actually afford it
which would not be tomorrow if tomorrow
they're for sale it's unlikely I get
them I may get a tiny tiny piece cuz
whoever got it is probably smart enough
to realize me getting a little piece is
probably a good Arbitrage but that will
crush me in my competitive Spirit of
trying it but if I don't get them
that'll be fine chasing them has been
the great joy of my
life and and that's what I want for
everyone where the process is enjoyable
I think a lot of people struggle with
goals when they hit it it's so empty
they're like [__] [__] like getting to a
million or 100,000 or whatever it is
what like they feel empty I'm sure many
people here have achieved something that
they can think back now is like [__] it
wasn't as good as I thought because the
ideology of the thing was what they put
on a pedestal not the day-to-day game of
trying to get to the thing and so when I
when I'm at a conference like this with
all the other incredible speakers you've
got lined up and I think about like what
could we touch on in this talk that
might bring back that might not be
touched on I just don't think Dan people
put enough energy on enjoying it it's
like winning at all costs is fine but
not at your
cost you know it's just not and at 47
years old and being around the game for
a long time now and knowing how many
people got to the top of the mountain on
paper and lost their lives their loved
ones lost everything once they got there
because of how they got there like all
all the [__] all the [__] [__] that
comes along with it I don't want that
for a single [__] person at this
[Applause]
conference so we have 7,000 people in
this
audience and they're going to be
surrounded by people that are not going
to support them and when they have the
crazy idea I'm going to open a sports
card store in the middle of a shutdown
I'm going to open up asaio locations or
I'm going to throw a humongous event
they have these ous ideas and they're
finally excited to do it and their
friends don't support them what are your
thoughts about the people that's the
best the greatest thing in the world for
an entrepreneur is sticking it to their
[__]
[Applause]
friends I got nothing else to [__]
say about that like yeah like like
honestly I never get mad at anyone not
my friends not my competitors not people
that troll me not I'm empathetic people
are going through their [__] if your
friends don't support you it's because
they can't see them doing it understood
it's because they're unhappy and they're
starting to develop a little envy and
jealousy of you not because they don't
love you anymore or they're not your
homie they're just not in a good place I
think too many of us that are succeeding
are not doing a good enough job bringing
our friends along from a place of
empathy compassion and sympathy don't be
mad at them have compassion for
them you know what I mean I think a lot
of us know what we mean right we're like
no [__] Don he just he's [__] jealous
[__] Don your boy that you grew
up with is just in a tough spot right
now deep down he's super pumped for you
he's just not in a good place you need
to [__] be double friend not cut them
off
so
so someone's out there they're listening
to you they've been listening for years
and they're finally ready they're going
to post multiple times a day they're
building their following they hit 10,000
followers they're excited and then they
start to see five trolls a day 12 12
comments a day you're ugly you're rude
you're stupid that's dumb how do you say
to deal with trolls and haters yeah I
mean we just touched on it like just
like honestly once and for all because I
know a lot of you on your Journeys will
have public you know lives like
genuinely stick with me on this for two
seconds imagine living a life where
right now on this Saturday morning
afternoon around this country you're
laying at home and you're going through
your Instagram or Tik Tok or YouTube and
you're looking to hurt someone else's
feelings like you're literally going
through it to find you're looking to get
triggered or upset to then leave a
comment to then hurt that person think
about how sad that life
is honestly I mean it I'm not making fun
of that person I'm deeply empathetic to
that person think about how [__] sad
that life is that you're not in the
business of building something you're in
the business of walking around the
internet trying to tear something
down I I really really really hope that
this hits even one person here that
starting this moment from now on when
someone says you're ugly or stupid or
full of [__] or suck that you don't
start to feel bad for yourself you start
feeling sad for them please get on this
[__] train cuz it will be good for
you and it will make you a better person
for
[Applause]
them Dan literally I am always consuming
because I want to know what's going on
the only time I ever feel compelled to
say something is not and I disagree or
see the World differently than a lot of
people posting I'm not compelled to Raz
that person the only time I'm doing
anything is usually dming people in this
room saying keep going right like I'm
I'm trying to give love because I'm
happy inside what we do publicly is a
complete reflection of what's going on
inside the only time I feel compelled to
do something is to tell one of y'all
keep [__] going you're not
far so
sitting right next to that person that
did listen to you is the one that didn't
and they say to you I don't need social
media I don't need a personal brand what
would you say to them
cool there's unlimited people [__]
winning I know unlimited people with
monster businesses super happy lives and
they're not on social
melto you know good on the flip side
there's a lot of people that leave
opportunity on the table without
realizing friends social media is free
distribution of course you can run paid
I get it but it is the only platform in
the world that you can reach millions of
audience without paying for it do you
know how [__] insane that is you
can't run a newspaper ad for free you
can't run a television commercial for
free you can't buy Google AdWords for
free you can do SEO which is true which
is why it was a monster but the fact
that's social and especially with the
ticktock ification of everything is free
it's insane it it's so insane that I'm
just finishing up wrapping the followup
to jab jab jab right
hook um thank you uh originally it was
called jab jab jab left hook which I
liked but as I was writing it which is
the thesis I have on where we are right
now in the current state of the internet
and attention I re I I changed the title
of the book and now it's going to be
called day trading attention
and for everyone here the number one
thing that they're actually in need of
doing is day trading attention social is
an incredible place to do it influencers
is an incredible way to do it there's a
lot of ways to do it but it is the macro
thesis Dan when you're opening up
locations right for asai or or sports
cards or for donuts like J I'm met or
anything that anyone's doing here at the
end of the day before anyone's going to
buy anything from you they need to know
about it
and for me social media is
disproportionate on this day in 2023 the
biggest opportunity for time and effort
and money against outcome on the other
side so when people say I'm not going to
do it or I don't need it I'm very
empathetic to that there's many ways to
win this isn't the only way it just
happens to be the way especially for
someone starting at zero the most
opportunistic way today the same way
that if I was writing books when I was
building Wine Library for my dad I would
have talked about search CU SEO in 2000
was bananas and so there's always an ARB
and so I don't think anyone should do
anything other than be a kind person but
as far as entrepreneurship like I'm not
hurt I didn't invent social media social
media is not my [__] brother I don't
give a [__] I just think there's an
opportunity can you guys just clap if
you have
children for someone out there that has
a 14-year-old or a 16-year-old daughter
for example and she's comparing herself
to other girls on social media and
whether it's celebrities or influencers
or anything between what would you say
to those girls that are seeing so much
photoshopped content look I know how
much the world is excited about blaming
social media for everything and this
scenario I'm 47 years old our social
media was Kate Moss was being blamed for
[__] because of her photos in a magazine
and what her weight was we're always
blaming something Marilyn Monroe was
blamed Barbie was blamed Cindy Crawford
was blamed K Moss was blamed like
somebody's always to blame parents love
to blame the outside the only way to win
the game that all us parents want which
is we want our kids to not get caught up
in some [__] is for us to focus on
building the kids
self-esteem if it's
true like like there are millions and
millions and millions of young girls and
boys right now going through social
media and they're not devastated by
someone else's money or good looks or
happiness there's millions of them
they're the ones who were fortunate
enough with either DNA or great
parenting from everyone who just clapped
by instilling into that child that you
are good enough and these are are the
things you're good at where we lose our
way sometimes is we tell these little
[__] they're good at everything and
that's
delusion which is why we have to get rid
of eighth place trophies because they're
[__] us
up you do not build self-esteem by
telling your child they're great at
everything you build self-esteem by
pointing out the things your kids are
good at and pointing out the things they
could work on but once you build that
self-esteem they can deal with other
people's happiness
along the same lines someone's just
getting started on social media and
they're only getting 12 likes and 16
likes and they feel like well Johnny or
Rebecca sees that I only got 12 likes
and they feel weird about that what
would you say when they're first like
you used to get your first few views and
now you got tens of millions views walk
us through that first phase you still
suck I love it that's it next question
you know like sometimes people come to
be like Gary I yo [__] you Gary like
I've been doing it for seven years and I
have 1,800 followers and get two likes
I'm like bro you
suck and I don't say that to Raz him I'm
like it's not that it's like not that
social doesn't work because there's
billions of examples of it working it's
that you haven't found it like what
you're doing isn't resonating with the
world and that's on you to either not
and this is a real one not care because
you like doing it and [__] it you got
your 1,700 followers and you're [__]
living or if you want want something
else you've got to change it you got to
change the creative format you've got to
change the way you present you've got to
change maybe you shouldn't be in the
content you should be behind the scenes
there could be a million reasons but you
shouldn't dwell on where you're at you
know it again back to health and fitness
what I was doing in the gym 10 years ago
is very different than what I'm doing
now that [__] in the first month was
disastrous like like eight atrocious
push-ups you know what I mean I don't do
that anymore more because I put in the
[__] work and I put in the time and
so I think that a lot of people need to
realize where they are on the journey
and I do think people give up too soon
because the first year didn't go well
and they don't realize that they're just
starting it's about reps and you know I
think again this all goes into the
mindset [__] that I'm most fascinated
about most of the [__] that everyone
here is not achieving isn't based on
them not knowing the
tactics the tactics are available for
free you can go Google on YouTube
everything they're
free the the mindset that stops one from
doing it is the thing I'm most
fascinated by especially in entrepreneur
land just to remind everybody what we
all do for a living you're basically
losing all the
time this journey of building [__] is a
game of micro losing all the time and if
you get really good at micro losing you
tend to macro win and what that means is
there's always a little step backs but
if you take something from it and you
tweak and you build and you tweak and
then something else gets [__] up it's
like the whole you know the boat that
keeps having holes in it you know you're
on the boat and this thing's [__] up
you put your finger in it you patch it
up that's fixed but [__] two things
popped up over here everyone here is
micro losing I'm losing all the time we
lost a client this week we lost three
good employees that I didn't want to
lose you're constantly losing we need to
fall in love with losing this is where I
get serious about the eighth place
trophy the reason that that's dangerous
is we're teaching kids that losing is
bad when losing is actually the
best the best [__] entrepreneurs in
the world love to lose
promise so a moment ago and just notice
Dan just notice how light the claps were
on that yeah right like like just notice
what everyone just did there was a
couple people don't like to lose because
they worry about what other people
think whoa whoo is right
[__] people don't like to lose
cuz they're actually worried I don't
give a [__] what you think about my
losses not because I'm audacious or I'm
mean because it's like an athlete do you
understand could you imagine an athlete
stopping every time the home team the
home on crowd
booed I mean there wouldn't be a single
Jets player on
earth I'm booing with the first 8
Seconds of the
game like like you all of you are on the
[__]
field do you understand that all of you
were on the
field so it doesn't matter what your
[__] mom or uncle or sister say
they're on the [__] stands eating
popcorn watching you [__]
[Applause]
play like honestly like I I talked to
like friends and family proba they're
like Gary but my mom said look your mom
in the face and say Mom if you don't
think what I'm doing is right [__] go
show me you do something and let me look
at
that I'm not I'm not [__] worried
about people's opinions that are not on
the [__]
field
[__] so here in Salt Lake we have a lot
of people that are in the door to-door
space yes obviously the great one of our
sponsors when when you start making
money early these guys are 22 24 26
years old making 10 grand 20 grand 30
grand 40 Grand some of them 100 Grand in
a month or 200 Grand in the summer what
do you say the kids that are making
money like that at 22 24 26 so they
don't go yeah that [__] scares the love
[__] [__] out of
me um you know look I mean when you're
making that kind of money at that age
like
you re I really get worried because I'm
I'm wondering like what's going to
happen you know it's
cliche going back to what we just ranted
about so many people are living their
lives to impress everybody that they're
going to go take that money and buy dumb
[__] right it's going to burn a hole in
their pocket many of them are thoughtful
and will do smart [__] you know look I
don't think I think there's a million
things people could do in that scenario
and I don't think anything I'm about to
say is the right way
you've got to know your situation for
some of those people they're going to do
incredible things like payoff debt for
family members and remarkable things for
some of them they are going to buy a toy
and that's okay too I know I talk a lot
about you know people buying things and
people get mad at me they're like no
Gary I like this car and like if you
really like it you should be like I buy
tons of dumb [__] I buy custom jerseys
of fourth string Jets
players for $180 they may never play and
I buy it strictly to go to the stadium
and wear the Jersey to Peacock that I'm
the biggest Jets fan in the
stadium that's not smart you know so
they'll buy toys it's all fine I think
the biggest thing is at that young of an
age there's so much good you could be
doing with that but the biggest thing
that I think about that when I hear that
from you is finding your relationship
with money you know one thing I think we
all agree that is completely no longer
talked about is saving money that leads
to be like the only conversation in this
50s 60s '70s ' 80s '90s like I like
literally like look at Google Trends and
look search on social like nobody's
talking about saving money right and
when you come into money quickly in your
early 20s a lot of times you think it's
always going to be there and so we see a
lot of people in that scenario it comes
and then it's gone and they really and
they've already tasted having money so
now they're depressed because they're 26
and they have less at 26 than they had
at 22 and so these are the things I
worry about I just think building an
actual good relationship with money
where there's a balance between savings
investing buying some things to make you
and your family happy just finding a
balance
so thank
you an hour ago we had David gogins here
and I asked him about personal fitness
when it's like Thursday morning and they
don't really feel like it on the
business fitness side when someone's
been working on their business and they
don't have the results yet they've been
working on their business for a year or
two years whatever it is and they just
aren't having the results or things are
hard what would you say to them so when
they don't feel like it there's two
Extremes in this scenario in my opinion
one sometimes it's just okay to [__]
punt the day and I know that like like
it's like it's not necessarily what I do
but that's goes back to the way I
started this which is I love my [__]
[__] so much that even when it's going
bad it's like it's good cuz I'm playing
right actually this is really important
I I don't say this often for everyone
here just think of the single thing the
single game you like the best basketball
Uno poker bro Uno is the [__]
Jam poker whatever it is that single
game that you're thinking about right
now tennis that game that you love so
much you like playing it even when
you're losing as a matter of fact for a
lot of you like me when you lose it
makes the next game even more fun right
that's how business is and that's what I
want everybody to find for the people
that have that on that Thursday punt it
go spend time with your family I don't
know like Zen out it's actually okay to
skip the day right or to the The Other
Extreme push through super hard because
when you get through that day you've
shown yourself resilience and you get to
the end of the day you feel accomplished
don't be in the Middle where you're just
dwelling about the feeling all day if
it's really killing you get the [__] out
go to movie I don't care play video
games if it's not completely killing you
show yourself that you have resilience
to get through that 10-hour day and get
on the other side CU you will feel
[__] great but let's say you decided
to go through the resilience and you're
an hour or two in and it's even getting
worse then punt the day we have to be
nicer to ourselves Dan we just have to
be nicer to ourselves too many of you
are beating yourself up for little dumb
[__] one day of not productive work at
your job is not putting you the [__] out
of
business
so that being
said if that day becomes a week and that
week becomes a month now you got to look
at it you know what I mean now you got
to look at it now you're in the wrong
game and you need to figure out how to
get the [__] out
potentially in our last 30 seconds what
is the one thing you would say to this
audience that's getting bombarded by the
media and chaos and we're in inter
session everything's going wild and
there's so many things that are fear to
us what would you say to them to make
them not feel like that the truth which
is all of you are 100% in
charge it doesn't matter what I there
have been people that have been happy
and built monster businesses in
recessions during natural disasters with
a bad mom with an alcoholic dad there
are unlimited people in the world who
have found massive of success and deep
happiness in every scenario there is
nobody in control of you no matter what
they pound down your throat to scare you
I promise you you are 100 [__] per in
charge and the second you get that into
your [__] Dome is the second you
don't even hear the dumb [__] anymore
ladies and gentlemen get
[Music]
away
yeah